[Music]
Hello dear friends. This is Pastor David
Salasar and I'm with Pastor Steven
Boore. In this program that we know you
enjoy as much as we do, which is I'd
like to know. We want to invite you to
send your questions to our email address
which is tvsamtv.org
og and we may be able to receive those
questions so that we may have more
important things to discuss to research
to study and we thank you for your
contribution that makes this program
really relevant and and a joy to have I
have uh pastor bore this uh program now
that we're going to start but before we
start this study or answer the questions
we want to ask the holy spirit to lead
us into all truth so pastor bor if you
could lead us into prayer and we'll go
into the questions that we have for this
program.
>> Amen. Let's pray. Father in heaven, we
come before your awesome throne, the
King of the universe, the all- wise, all
knowing God. We have many questions that
perhaps in this life we're not going to
be able to answer. But when we get to
the kingdom, we'll have all of the
answers from your lips. We ask meanwhile
that during this program you will
enlighten our minds that you will give
us uh clarity of thought and of speech
to answer the questions according to
your holy word.
>> Amen.
>> We ask that you will be with us through
the ministry of your holy spirit in
Jesus name we pray. Amen.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Amen. Pastor Bo, we had uh last program
we were not able to answer fully a
question that I would like to again just
to make sure that we answer carefully
and uh the question comes from Gyrie or
Jerry and it's in regards to the
wedding. Let me once again read the
question and we'll try to answer a
little more in depth. It says there is
there a specific way a wedding ceremony
that is in the Bible because a common
wedding ceremony we see like wearing a
white gown and veils and rings is a
pagan ceremony. Last program we were
able to answer that the white garment
for a for a bride is actually a biblical
uh example has been used to determine
purity to determine a virgin and what
not. So that particularly is not
necessarily uh wrong. It's not a even
though pagan cultures could do that or
use that is not does not go against the
scriptures. But what about the rings or
veils? I mean what about that part? Is
that is that is there something about
that that is prohibited in the Bible
that is pagan that we should be aware
of?
>> Well, I think that uh um people can go
overboard when it comes to weddings.
in terms of great expenditures you know
on their wedding they end up in debt uh
and there's a lot of um how would I say
a lot of show uh in the wedding uh in
the Bible weddings were simple
>> uh you know like take the case of Adam
and Eve
>> exactly
>> you know God got them together and he
said male and female man shall he father
and mother be joined to his wife it was
a very short sermon right
>> and Um, and so I think that as time goes
by, we begin to adopt all kinds of
cultural customs. Some of them are okay,
like for example, using a white dress
>> uh, and the groom using a black suit.
You know, some of them are really
inoffensive.
>> But there are some that really go
overboard and um, for example, I never
perform wedding ring uh, wedding ring
ceremonies.
>> Yeah. Um, as a principle, I don't do
that because I don't think that a
wedding ring is necessary. I'm not
critical of people who conscientiously
use one
>> because I consider that a wedding ring
is different than than a nose ring or a,
you know, a bracelet or something like
that because it has a practical purpose.
It's not to exhibit. The purpose is to
announce that that person is married. I
can understand people that think that
way. Mhm.
>> I haven't found in my ministry that it's
been necessary at all having a wedding
ring because I behave like a married
man.
>> Amen.
>> I think it's your behavior really that
determines things more than whether you
have a wedding ring or you don't have a
wedding ring. And Ellen White clearly
says in testimonies ministers that it's
not really necessary. But there are some
customs, you know, like having
bridesmaids and groomsmen and things
like that. I mean, suppose that the
pagans used it. I mean there are many
things these days that we use that uh we
used also by pagans. For example, this
tie that I have on.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, ties are of pagan origin.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> But they're totally disconnected from
paganism these days. You know, it's just
uh the acceptable attire for someone who
is uh is, you know, presenting in a
serious environment,
>> right? Uh so that that's what I would
say
>> and and you know pastor I mean in
regards to the wedding ceremony itself
as you said perhaps the best example in
the Bible is the example in in Eden uh
which was considered you know uh before
everything that before sin it was the
experience of God blessing the union of
man and wife and um it was simple it was
a experience of joy for both and for the
Lord. So and Christ then also having
attending the wedding in Kaa shows that
he sanctions and he blesses that union
and the wedding in those days uh lasted
for several days and therefore uh could
we say that it has to last several days
today? Probably not because it will be
too expensive. So we have to be use
sound judgment in regards to what should
we do in regards to a wedding. Now, it
should be made uh special as much as
possible, but not also, as you said, not
go overboard in in in cost. Uh I've
heard a friend who wanted to have a
wedding and you know, like you said, had
to get in debt. And that does make
sense. That was just the wrong way to
approach to start a life together, you
know, with a big uh expense like that.
>> And you know, uh take for example
bridesmaids. The Bible does speak of
bridesmaids, not in that word. Uh you
know, when uh Jesus gave the parable of
the 10 virgins. Yeah,
>> you know, there were lamps and there was
a procession to the wedding chamber and
there was a closing of the door once all
the guests were in. Um, you know, if
paganism had some of those customs, uh,
it wouldn't necessarily uh be wrong to
uh follow the cultural practices of the
day as long as they don't contradict
biblical principles.
>> Correct. Uh and and in the case of the
veil, one example we have of of the veil
is for example uh Rebecca when she was
coming and she saw her husband to be
Isaac, she put a veil on, you know, kind
of a a sign of covering until the moment
they will be married. So these things
could be applied. There's not really
necessarily I mean of of course they
were kind of in an experience where a
lot of customs were also part of their
their environment. I mean she even wore
a ring. That doesn't make it right. It's
just some things that were biblical in
the past. Some of them can be applied.
Some of them should we should look into
all the information that the Lord has
given us. All the light we have now and
say such custom is not necessarily
important or not applicable to us and
some of them are harmless like you said.
So we we have to s just ask for the Lord
to guide us and to be uh willing to take
in consideration everything the Lord has
revealed in order to make a right
decision
>> whe whether you eat or drink or whatever
you do.
>> Amen.
>> Do all to the glory of God. Amen.
>> Not to the glory of yourself. That's a
principle.
>> Amen. All right. So now Jarai or Jiri uh
I I I'm sorry if I mispronounce your
name but um he also sends another
question and is an interesting question
and one that perhaps is important to
answer. It says in case of emergency
and someone once needs to be baptized
but in the absence of an ordained pastor
can any person be allowed to perform the
baptism?
Pastor, what can we say about this
question?
>> Okay. Uh, sometimes there are
extenduating circumstances.
Let me give you an example that does not
directly answer the question, but it
provides an example.
>> Uh, people always bring up the thief on
the cross.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, Jesus says, "Whoever believes
and is baptized will be saved,
>> right?
>> Whoever isn't is lost." So, as far as we
know, the thief on the cross was never
baptized. So, he's going to be lost,
right?
>> No.
It's an extenduating circumstance. And
God takes into account extenduating
circumstances. Um, he couldn't get
baptized.
He was hanging on the cross. He was a
thief until the very moment when he said
to Jesus, "Remember me in your kingdom."
He had been reviling Christ along with
the other thief. Right?
>> But then he had a change of heart.
So he is going to be saved because Jesus
said very clearly, "You will be with me
>> in the kingdom."
>> So he's going to be saved. And he was
never baptized.
>> Does that mean that uh when I make a
call for baptism, uh somebody says, "Oh,
I don't have to respond to that call
because because you know, I have Jesus
in my heart. I don't have to be
baptized." It doesn't apply there.
>> Exactly. uh because you the one is the
exception and the other is the rule,
right?
>> And they say that the the exception
makes the rule.
>> Uh so that's one example where sometimes
they're extenduating circumstances that
uh cause an individual to do something
which is not uh commonly doing. Mhm.
>> Um in the case of baptism, uh the spirit
of prophecy makes it very clear that
only those ministers who are ordained
should baptize and should officiate the
Lord's supper
>> and and the ordinances of the church. Uh
she's very clear on that. And the Bible
also Jesus set aside the 12 to go out
and preach and to go out and baptize. Uh
but there's one case I think that'll
help us in this situation.
>> Right.
>> Probably many of those who are watching
are acquainted with the story of the
mutiny and the bounty.
>> Mhm. Uh you know there was this mutiny
uh Captain Blie I remember you know he
rebelled against England and um to make
a long story short um the people who
were on the bounty ended up in an island
in the Pacific called Pit Karen
>> right
>> and there was an individual by the name
of John
>> Jhm
>> John Tay excuse me John Tay who went
there as a missionary
and he preached a series of sermons and
the whole island was converted Right.
>> And so, uh, the people wanted to be
baptized because they accepted the
Adventist message. And, uh, John Tay
said, "I'm sorry, I'm not ordained. I
can't baptize you."
>> Mhm.
>> But, I'll come back.
Well, he eventually did come back, but
Ellen White later wrote a testimony to
him.
>> And he said to him, even though he
wasn't ordained, he said, "You should
have," she said, "you should have
baptized those people." Mhm.
>> Now, he wasn't ordained, so he should
never baptized, right? This is a case of
extenduating circumstances where it was
not possible
>> for him to be ordained before he
baptized them. And maybe some of those
people died between when they made their
decision to be baptized and uh when he
came back. Uh so uh you know the by the
way if somebody's interested in the
source for that um manuscript 75
>> 1896 paragraph 4 uh Ellen White speaks
about uh you know cases where
individuals who are not ordained can
baptize. Um by the way he arrived on
October 18, 1886
and then he left the last week of
November. He was only there 5 weeks
>> for the evangelistic crusade. And um and
so uh you have an exception there. It
doesn't mean that everybody should now
go baptizing people.
>> Right. Right.
>> It means that an ordained minister
should do it. But if you're way out in
the tulies and somebody uh requests
baptism and there's not a minister that
can come there, uh the exception makes
the rule.
>> Absolutely. And and the church has made
provision for for certain scenarios as
uh also ordained elders can be with
approval of the you know local
jurisdiction of church
>> uh kind of give them that that power to
do that in those in situations where
difficult but like you said u in perhaps
in a situation where somebody's really
sick and is really you know about to die
um there's provision for those scenarios
right by the blood of Christ and his
sacrifice and his baptism himself.
But um you know let's let's try to keep
this in mind and and keep that balance
as you well have said pastor before.
>> Yeah. God God has has an organized
church.
>> Yeah.
>> And that organized church sets aside
ministers to perform the ordinances.
>> That's the rule. That's the way it
should be.
>> But if there's an exceptional case
>> Yeah.
>> like the thief on the cross who was not
baptized.
>> Yeah. where there's not a minister that
can do the baptizing, then uh God
accepts uh the the person baptized. I
had a case of this, you know, I I just
got back a while ago from Colombia
>> where where I had a series of meetings
on uh Pentecost on the outpouring of the
Holy Spirit. And there was an individual
there that came to me and said, "You
know, I have a pastor in my district
that has never gone to visit a certain
place way out in in the jungle."
>> And he says, "The pastor refuses to go
there. It's very, very difficult to get
there. You have to travel several days.
You have to travel by by uh, you know,
canoe." and uh he just he just doesn't
go there. And and I said, "It's his
responsibility to go there." And his
question was uh there's a group of
people there that want to be baptized,
but there's no one to baptize them. So
So what how can this be resolved? I
said, "Well, first of all, you have to
report it to the conference."
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> And tell them this is part of his field.
>> Yeah.
>> No matter how difficult it is, if
there's people that want to be baptized,
uh you should go and baptize them. But
if in worst case scenario u nobody uh is
willing to go and baptize those people
would it be wrong for a lay person who
actually brought the message to them to
baptize them? I don't think so.
>> Correct. I think that's again that
example of LG White applies to this
example as well. Right.
>> So thank you for those questions. I pray
that it has been a blessing to you. Now
we have another question pastor. This
one comes to us from Texas from Jose and
his question is this according to
Galatians 3 10-12
which law brings a curse and is that
that law that was contrary to us in
Colossians 2:14 because of the curse and
oath written in the law of Moses then
line 11. So
his I his question is which law brings a
curse which is what law is he speaking
of uh here Paul in Galatians 3:10-12.
>> Well very clearly he's speaking about
the moral ten commandment law.
>> Um maybe it' be a good idea to read
those verses.
>> Absolutely. That's where
>> Galatians 3 10 actually uh you need to
read verses 10 to13.
>> Correct. I'm reading here from the New
King James Version, Galatians 3:10-13.
For as many as are of the works of the
law are under the curse, for it is
written, curses everyone who does not
continue in all things which are written
in the book of the law to do them. But
that no one is justified by the law in
the sight of God is evident. For the
just shall live by faith. Yet the law is
not of faith, but of the man who does
them shall live by them. Christ has
redeemed us from the curse of the law,
having become our curse for us. For it
is written, "Cursed is everyone who
hangs on a tree."
>> Clearly, this is talking about the ten
commandments.
>> Mhm.
>> You know, because Jesus, it says here
that Jesus took the curse.
>> Yeah.
>> So, we don't have to suffer the curse.
you know, it's not talking there about
the ceremonial laws that God gave the
Jewish nation,
>> right?
>> It's talking about the ten commandments.
>> Um, and uh, then we have the the passage
in Colossians
>> Mhm.
>> that he mentions in Colossians chapter 2
and verse 14.
Colossians 2:14,
having wiped out the handwritten of
requirements that was against us, which
was contrary to us, and he has taken it
out of the way, having nailed it to the
cross.
>> Okay. Well, let's read a little bit of
the context. Let's start at verse 11.
In him you were also circumcised with
the circumcision made without hands by
putting off the body of the sins of the
flesh by the circumcision of Christ
buried with him in baptism in which you
also were raised with him through faith
in the working of God who raised him
from the dead. And you being dead in
your trespasses and the uncircumcision
of your flesh, he has made alive
together with him, having forgiven you
all trespasses, having wiped out the
handwritten of requirements that was
against us, which was contrary to us,
and he has taken it out of the way,
having nailed it to the cross.
>> Okay. uh the the word that is used here
uh for uh for uh the handwriting of of
requirements some say handwriting of
ordinances
>> is the Greek word kerograph
which means a debt bond
>> now in the the whole old testament
system was a system of debt
>> right
>> you know when the sinner took the animal
to the sanctuary
>> yes
>> uh he would confess his sin on the head
of the animal and uh then shed the blood
of the animal. The blood was taken into
the sanctuary. The sin was forgiven. But
it was only conditionally forgiven.
>> Yeah.
>> Because Christ is the only one who can
remove sin. And
>> so so Christ had to come and he had to
pay for the debt of the person. Right.
In other words, the sacrifice of the
animal was an IOU.
>> Exactly.
>> Where Jesus was saying,
>> I'll come and I'll pay I'll pay the
bill. So, but sign the IOU now.
>> Yeah. And when Jesus came, he took away
the
>> IOU
>> because he actually paid the price.
>> So So this here is talking about the the
moral law of the ten commandments. It's
talking about the debt bond that people
in the Old Testament had which was
removed when Christ legally took care of
sin.
So then as he's mentioning in this
question he's trying to understand which
law brings a curse or what is that law
again is the ten commandments law that
was the evident in Galatians speaking of
that the curse of the law was put on
Christ. the debt paid by Christ. And
therefore in Colossians is also allowing
us to understand that Christ took away
that debt system,
>> the IOU,
>> the IOU system, right?
>> And has enabled us to now have that
assurance of pardoning and receiving
pardon immediately as we come to him.
>> And you know, you can find this clearly
in the book of Romans.
>> Um Romans chapter 3. Uh very interesting
passage. Um we've read it in another
context before. Uh in Romans chapter 3
25 and 26 it says um uh let's go to
verse 23 for the context. For all have
sinned
>> yes
>> g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g
g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g g
glory of God. Uh so when it says all
have sinned, it means that you've
transgressed the law because sin is
transgression of the law.
>> Correct? Then it continues saying here,
being justified freely by his grace
through the redemption that is in Christ
Jesus,
>> whom God set forth as a propitiation
by his blood through faith.
>> Yeah.
>> And now comes the key portion to
demonstrate his righteousness. Because
in his forbearance, God had passed over
the sins that were previously committed.
Mhm.
>> to demonstrate at the present time his
righteousness that he might be just and
justifier of the one who has faith in
Jesus. So basically he had passed over.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh the the final pun punishment for sin
in the Old Testament system
>> but when Jesus came the IOU was paid. No
longer were we indebted. And pastor, you
know, this question uh that often comes
to to those, you know, well, isn't
Colossians telling us then that the ten
commandments was nailed to the cross
that you know that the that by him
taking that debt system that includes
the moral law of God or the ten
commandments of God. um how can we sort
of what give them understanding that is
not the ten commandments that are nailed
necessarily but just the uh the debt the
outu part
>> of that.
>> Okay. Well, that's a good question. You
know, let me give you an example. You
come to a a red traffic light. What are
you supposed to do?
>> Stop.
>> You're supposed to stop, right? The law
tells you to stop,
>> right?
>> What happens if you run through it uh
without stopping and there's a cop
nearby?
He's going to pull you over.
>> You're under the curse of the law,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Because you're going to get a ticket.
>> Right. Right.
>> So, you're under the curse of the law.
So, the best solution to the problem is
to get rid of the policeman.
>> No.
>> You crucify the policeman and the
problem is solved. No. Uh the solution
>> is for the policeman to give you the
ticket and then go down to the to the
court and pay for your ticket.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now, it's going to never
happen in real life.
>> Never happen. Yeah.
>> But but you know, the bottom line is
that Christ paid our debt.
>> Mhm.
>> On the cross. But that doesn't mean that
there's no longer any sin.
>> Correct.
>> If there's no law, there's no sin.
>> Yeah.
>> And if there's no sin, there's no death.
>> If there's no death, we're immortal.
That's what that's what the devil
teaches.
>> Yeah. So basically um it is our debt
that is taken away not the law that
caused us to get indebted.
>> Amen. Thank you pastor for that
important uh you know explanation and we
thank you again for allowing us to come
to you with this program. We are always
uh thanking you for your prayers and for
your continual support that allows us to
continue to make these programs and to
be able to be a blessing to many around
the world. God bless you. Looking
forward to see you here next time.
[Music]
Heat.